no I think we are all set now extract hi
hi this is custody I may know who are
all there now online so she can give a
short introduction but your sons are to
be awesome may know who are all there
now so you can give a short introduction
but your sensor to be also that you turn
off your phone please turn off your
microphone
okay yeah I can hear you yeah yeah so he
will please mute all other microphones
because we listen us hello
hi do y'all hear me yep they oh they can
yeah holy yeah okay who's this this is
Anand hi Ireland I think it's you and
I'm just trying to see who are all there
in London and then who's this this is
Rajesh
this is Rajesh no - Rajesh hi Rajesh hi
hello Rajesh is new up sorry I can hear
you yeah oh you can hear me right okay
and who's the other person who's this
nice Raj I guess he doesn't have a mic
or something like that so I guess we can
continue now he doesn't have a mic okay
but he will be just able to see what's
happening yeah and and it's for all the
participants if there is any doubt we
have hangout chat box okay drop your
text over there all right Oregon Tech
website alright and we have a child here
there is another participant ciao
so how many of you are so you had a good
session on bioinformatics yesterday you
are all comfortable with the datasets
hello yes okay and you can do a PC and
everything here okay so how many of you
have worked with yeah okay and you all
have our studio installed mediators no
yes yes
yeah our studio okay and do you also
know about our markdown yes okay but
anyway so let's get started with basic
are marked okay I hope you are all able
to see my screen here
yes yes okay so basically go ahead and
start a new are markdown file the way
you do it is go to file and open a new
file and then you go to our markdown
click on our markdown and you can title
make a title any title that you want I'm
marking it as test and then I'm creating
a new markdown file called test okay so
one of the big or important thing that
you may you may have to consider in mind
before you do any bioinformatics
analysis is to produce a reproducible
cold okay reproducibility is a big issue
of nouns so many stuffs you know so many
research are happening without we are
not able to reproduce some of the
results and the main problem is that
there are so many you know analysis
being done it several places and using
several methods and no huge amount of
data so it comes at all there is a
problem at every levels and so a
consistent level of maintaining the code
and the documentation around the code is
absolutely important okay and that is
why there has been set up if you think
about Python or you have the Jupiter
notebooks or if you have the are you
have this are markdown and these are
mekin these are applications that are
built around the central application
both are as well as a Python to in order
to actually have a consistent
documentation found around your code so
whenever I am starting a new analysis by
informatics analysis I now you know make
a new armor file so the challenge would
be that you can do ad hoc you will do a
doc analysis and you get back to your
code maybe in two months time and then
find yourself you know you will not be
able to understand what you data at all
so that's that's that's going to be a
big challenge and that is why it's best
to have you
code and at one place and also the
documentation around it so if you can
create one let's say for analysis and
our markdown file you would be able to
go back to your analysis even after a
year or two years doesn't matter you
will be able to understand everything
and then you would be able to proceed
the analysis just like how you are how
you know how you did like two years back
and another important aspect of having
an our markdown is that it is
transferable right so you can just pass
down the document to anybody it's not
just you anybody who's going to follow
up your analysis or who interested in
your analysis or going to read through
your code very easily okay so that's one
of the biggest change so just instead of
writing a script and having a
documentation around script somewhere
else you can all organized in one big
setup in our okay yes where we can find
this file okay so you this file is
automatically generated so go to file
you have an off studio right yes this
isn't brand-new so if you just go to
file and then create our markdown file
it's going to open this file up so there
if you open it up there are a few things
in there which is title author date
output Exeter exit line these are
actually the AML format so these are
going to be printed just like how it is
being what it's being supplied so you
can change the author you can change the
date and output right there are several
options for an output it could be an
HTML output or it could be a PDF
document or it could be a word document
and one don't provides several options
for generating the documents okay so
those are the first few here and there
are several options that are available
let's not go into them there is a big
you know a set of things that you could
do with a panda awk and you can create
so many of the things we want a
different table you know if you want to
customize your March
PDF documents you can specify a whole
lot of thing using that but let's not go
into all those things today we are going
to go over some basic stuffs for you to
get set it up and then go from there
okay and also you so when you come it
will automatically generate some of
these things so any are code that you're
right right is embedded in the first
courts like if you have these courts
right so whatever our code that you set
up or you write can be can be written
down under this with these three three
code symbol it's it's not a quote it's a
it was single
what's count it's the first character
under your escape key right so you can
start something like our so this just
means that it's a understands that it's
going to be our code and whatever that
you're right it's going to be
interpreted as our right and what you
can do is that you can run these things
that's the beauty of it that you can
immediately run and then it's going to
give you the result just like that right
whatever that you're going to do in the
console in our you can do it in our
markdown all you need to go as go and
run the chunks these are called cold
chunks okay so you can have a bunch of
code chunks by the way if you are having
any question please feel free to stop me
anytime okay all right hello yeah sure
sure because I mean it this looks weird
because it's like you know it just feels
like I'm just talking without at least
in the classroom when I teach I have
students who at least not of sleep I
mean all right so so all the things that
you can do is you can put these things
in the markdown and these two headers
right generally these quotes double code
is for the header and the size of the
header so you can have like a three size
three and you can have up to five sizes
for these headers okay and you can write
whatever
but you want you can write it with the
header symbol so these are the header
symbols and we can write everything
whatever that we want to fill it in
you can fill it in here right and you
can include plots too and that's usually
done within the R code when you have R
this is an example of a pressure and
there are so many options we will we
will look into the options a little bit
later but what one can do is that as
soon as you write finish writing this
small town there is something called
knit you all see that knit here just
click on that net ok so it's going to
come up it's going to ask for a place
where it's going to knit this document
so I can just say that it's going to be
in the same place as this do it some
name and then I'm going to need it so
once I need this document it's going to
produce a report for me in HTML ok and
that exactly has whatever that's being
done right there right it has the name
the title the author the date and the
core chunks okay and it's also going to
include the plots in here whatever plot
ok now once you know these basics you
can now manipulate so many things that
you want to and there is a there is a
big there is a primer for it if you go
and search our markdown sheet I can
copy/paste this you can look into the
options that you can give so for
instance you can have header list of
headers the size of the header and what
exactly does it give so simple plain
text you can just type in a plain text
and each line with two spaces to start a
new paragraph and if you want to have
italics it's just one one star symbol or
underscore symbol so for instance here
if
I'm going to say like you can also embed
vlogs in italics I can put like this for
instance and then knit it right it's
going to produce a document with that
italics you can also embed floss in
italics and you can change colors you
can change fonts any HTML tags that you
do you can put it in here also if you
are you can put latex symbols in here so
for math equations and stuff like that
you can also embed latex symbols here so
it's a very versatile programming
interface and editor that you would be
able to you know document everything
within that encoding code and equations
and min line equations so if you look
into the spread the the the cheat sheet
will be able to see what are all the
stuff you can put it as an itemized
things you can put an ordered list or
ordered list also it can have different
types of tables as well one of the
advantage is that there are so many
things that you can do in when creating
tables now in for the code chunks you
can have several options inside the core
chunk for instance you can just make
like four here right in our our markdown
sheet
I made these one plus two to be seen
right and that gave me three here I can
hide this from the output all I need to
do is that I have to say echo equals
false so here instead of our say a cou
equals and that's going to if I if I
need with that it's going to suppress
that output one plus two and it's just
going to give me three here and there
are so many options that are available
or here you can make it not evaluate the
entire statement sometime you may want
to do that
and also echo rather to display the code
along with the results or you can have a
warning sometimes some programs give you
warning and this is going to suppress
all the warnings you can have an error
message and this can stop giving the
error messages if you say it set it as
false and also for there are also
figures options like you can set the
figure width
figure length and things like that
almost I did almost all of my website
using our markdown you know so so many
things that you can do and actually you
can put it as a slideshow as well so
that hopefully gives you a basic idea on
markdown you need to you know work with
it to see what you like and you may as
an exercise you may want to create your
CV on that as well so that that might be
a good idea to produce an AR markdown
you know a CV it's a very neat interface
any questions actually I think I'm use
the staffing grief sharing files or lean
lanes actually no I did not okay yeah I
did not I I just opened an are markdowns
okay so let's go into so once you know
how to work with our markdown we can
actually go ahead and see some of the
results of visualization and exploration
in in RNA seek okay so basically data
exploration right I mean data science if
you think about data science what is
data science what do you think about
data science anything that is associated
with you know how do you know what we
get from the data you know looking at
analyzing it or you know any
manipulations or anything that we get
out of data is data science right
anything what you get out of data is
data science like what do you mean I'm
everything is data right for that matter
right right right means in some you know
the the process of analyzing and
visualizing it and then you know getting
it across the board and all three is the
main part is analyzing and visualization
right so okay
it's statistics and data science it's
data analysis this is data analysis okay
so data analysis is different from data
science analysis is a part of three data
science it's not different but it's a
part of it okay it's a part of it so so
data science is much more than data
analysis right right yes
so what other things does it encompass a
big thing from Daedra
you mean like a machine learning kind of
a thing yeah yeah well that's also part
of analysis right now so let's put it
this way right means it's acquiring
organizing interpreting you know
visualizing it and you know getting it
across the board solution so everyone
need not understand the raw data right
so you have to put it in a way that the
other people can understand it
so all this whole package is data
science essentially right well in a way
but let's look at what Google has to say
I mean I may just let's look at some of
the image just to see what data science
some of these people say yeah so one of
the Venn diagram says that it's computer
science mathematics statistical research
data processing and machine learning but
that is actually a nice
let's see yeah this is one of the cool
diagrams that I like okay so you have
hacking skills okay which is actually a
critical part of data science but also
math and statistics knowledge if you
have math and statistics knowledge and
hacking you probably get into machine
learning you should also have
substantiative expertise in a domain so
that's the domain of I mean domain is
very important so you know if you have
hacking skills and expertise it's going
to be a danger zone I kind of like this
definition but there is also another
definition that that they say it's data
science you have computer science math
and all it encompasses all of it like
this like what you are saying but you
know the most important aspect of any of
these things is that it is driven by
curiosity which is not covered in any of
these things it has it curious enough to
search the data look into the data and
how it leads you right I think that's
the most that's the engine that is
empowered that's that's propelling data
science so if you like you know it's it
is it is kind of bridging academia and
industry nowadays because in industry
there's no that was like knows looking
for exploration it's a it was confined
to academics more than industry but now
you know since we are acquiring also
data then what we can interpret it is
kind of bridging the gap between
industry and academia so one of the key
things is to basically be curious to
understand what the data is telling us
turn to chase after you know some of the
patterns that we see and that is what it
constitutes so I don't want to digress
here too much at the point I was trying
to convey is that one of the key things
in such you know curious curiosities
about doing things again and again right
you will be generating so many
hypotheses you will be quickly testing
them and you'll be repeating it over and
over again right so the idea is to
actually generate so many leads and
visualization is a critical for a data
exploration and then
absolutely there are so many
visualization tools that are propped up
or you own from biology background or
you all from a different background as
well okay and I think is also biologists
know okay but but the thing is that
visualization I don't know if you know
about set first plots right there is
another great tool for visualization and
there is another visualization is key
for doing any data science okay
and and what we will do is that today go
over some basics of visualization and
I'm I'm not sure if you know about
ggplot have you heard of ggplot so for
visualization the the paradigm used to
be that oh you can generate a bar chart
or we can generate a pie chart or or
some basic line chart line graph and
things like that but a we come and we
can thought about it and we saw that
there are certain elements that are
common across all graphics and one of
their are based
ad graphics made of layers okay the
layers could be there are different
types of layers one of them could be
coordinates you have any chart will have
some sort of any aesthetics and it might
have points or lines which are called
jobs and it may have different types of
recover coordinates yeah and it could be
you know some form of a some form of a
you know there are point jobs they are
line jobs there are different types of
layer that can be embedded to make any
graphics that you see so that's the idea
behind doing a visualization using a
layered approach and that is what we are
going to do today of getting familiar
with RNA seek data that you did
yesterday using this layered approach
okay so go ahead and install the the
package called PI D worse you all know
about this package
Stivers go hydrogen so install Thai
rivers
all of you know how to install an Arabic
package in our studio um can you take us
through yeah okay just go to console and
say install dot practice reverse
it's loading this you don't have it
please let us know when it will be
installed yeah yeah we installed it
already
okay
happy thanksmas
yeah so yes that's going to pull up the
data package one second here I'll get
back to you so most of the stuff already
packages you can look for search for
package and you or you can you can
download it from the ARMA source ours
are these website
which one is she like yeah so it depends
on the application like Meghna like for
instance something let's say that you
are trying to do you are trying to
develop a protocol for it depends on
specific line that you are coding trying
to code and if you want to do something
that's already existing you look for
basically it's trying to search for
Google Google the exact the what you
really want in there but usually when
you come to the domain of expert like
you know if you are in finance for
instance and if you are wanting to
develop a package for it there would be
lots of that big community of developers
who have developed the package for you
have think so you just download that and
when you use it I mean there is no right
methodology to identify you know what
people might have different names for
different packages that they do right so
what was your question again sorry I got
it download it yeah okay so so you got
this Arvind
yes I have our kernel and also the tidy
where's okay okay so basically what I
did was yesterday you you work with
these seven thousand genes right I put
that in this in this link and put it I
have uploaded into get so you can go
ahead and type in these things like the
URL I made I broke this URL into two
pieces so that you know it's just two
lines instead of one line and I just
made a paste and but instead you can
just have one big line of consisting of
these two URLs one link and then I do a
read dot CSV and I import the data in
here the RNA seek in here
okay so you can start typing it in the
console yeah yeah you can you can you
can create an R markdown for instance it
doesn't really take much to create an
our markup right if you can open a our
markdown file and you can create but if
you want to cut and paste also actually
there is let me try to see this what's
that yeah
[Music]
okay you can actually cut and paste from
here to link with you here so what I'm
doing here is basically importing the
data I shared the the link with you so
you should be able to in that or you
also knows you're not in Skype okay so
[Music]
yeah it's under workshops that
all right so what I'm doing here is
basically getting the RNA seek data and
then I want to import the row names I
want to make a data frame to do analysis
okay so for me I want to get the rows as
the patient's right there are 52
patients and the columns as gene names
right one of the key things that you
will do when you are doing data science
is that 80% of the time you would be
struck with cleaning the data maybe the
rest of the time like 20% would go on
doing some machine learning or
predictive analytics but most of the
time you would be manipulating how to
get the data into right format and
taking out all the removing all the
unwanted variables or you know missing
data and things like that so it's very
important to get these things right so
what you do is that you go here I want
to make a data frame first of all I want
to have a clean data to work with and
that data that I want the columns to be
in the gene names and the rows to be in
to be the patient IDs okay so I can have
an attribute for every patient several
attributes for every patient so that's
the required format but when you import
the data you will see that this
important RNA seek data is in the
reverse way right you you will have the
genes as the crows and the patient IDs
as the column so the first thing is that
I want to change this so I have to get
all the gene names and that's what I am
doing here G names and calling it as row
names of imported RNA seek and then I
want to make a patient ID variable okay
to make our data frame I want the
patient ID and so I append the patient
ID and the gene names and make a column
names okay so this is the column names
that I want
the column dips the stud should start
with the patient ID and have all the G
names in there okay now I want the
matrix inside it right and that matrix
is actually the RNA seek data that we
had is steady but it's going to be
transposed of it right so it just
transpose the RNA seek data here okay so
if I look into the original data once
you do it you will see that the original
data is about two nine one seven columns
and sorry two nine one seven rows and
1552 columns okay so I I want the
expression I transpose this and change
it into numeric and then I want each of
those patient had a group information
right do you recall that luminal basal
normal like yes so I want to have the
group information associated with each
patient right so I'm putting that as
well
so any questions so far okay so now one
of the key things that I want to do is
that I see that it's all ensembl genes
and I want to have an official gene
names and if you look into this package
or dot hechas or EG dot DB
there is a there is a package and that
helps us convert this ensemble that
ensembl into official gene names okay so
go ahead and install this library it's
going to ask if you want to install
everything and compile everything you
just say no just install this package
org dot H s dot e zero dB
let me know if you're done okay so I can
proceed yeah I'm done okay so so once
you have we can load the library right
and then we can have a change the names
of I just want to have the ensemble
names so once you see that the official
gene names can have several transcripts
so we have to have multiple mapping here
right and and once we have these
multiple mappings there will be some
rows which will have no data so I know
meet all the data in here so we'll make
this data frame with official gene names
that we will be using so so that it
becomes easier for me to do the rest of
the analysis okay so that's what I'm
doing here I'm making the data frame
here with rows 52 and columns 6 6 8 0
because I'm going to have 2 more rows
one for the group and the other for the
patient ID and once I make this I can
make a matrix and this matrix is what
I'm going to do now use for rest of the
analysis ok so the first part in any
data science or data analysis
application that you use just to bring
what kind of a you know into the right
format that you would be using so once
we do that we can create the ggplot
right so once we do that we have a try
Reavers and we you know like load the
library tiny words and create this plot
ggplot right d theta equal to just do it
right now but I'm going to tell you what
this all means okay and you should be
able to see for these two genes that we
discussed yesterday
DCAM an EP cam the expression values in
here can you instruct okay yeah so
warning Oh Rajesh he has a problem in
installing this package it's not
available
alright so to install that package right
there is another way to do that what you
do is go to bioconductor and this should
help you install it resource say slows
and then say C BioLite yeah it looks
like it's an art file what's that
it looks like an art code which one oh
yeah hey what should I do with this file
which file the one that you sent me the
link here the bio bio se like oh that's
going to download that if you are
already if you have already downloaded
the HS dot e g dot DB forget it
no I didn't I couldn't you put it so you
have to use the source dot by a
conductor in the console yes okay
it's not available still why what does
it say if sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
adding it in a mistake
the um so what should I wear today to
type inside the install.packages source
all the way to dB
yeah so by OC light or dot when you type
in it's going to ask for whether it
should be install all of them right
I usually give s but it's going to take
some time to install under install
packages what should go into the into
the parentheses appearances from source
source HTTP bioconductor right I mean
yeah till till our till dot R yes still
dot off yeah and then the parentheses
yeah so this one that I'm highlighting
here
now it still says it's not available for
the packets can I type just it's not
available what what exactly does the
error I get sorry even if you type in
source yeah you can see I just sent him
I think the more easier way initially is
to just type it you know cut copy paste
it in console right yeah directly
console and hit run yeah that should
that's what it yeah yeah don't install
packages yeah let's go to console and
just type and peel cut and paste yeah I
don't I mean forget the install package
isn't there yeah it's now it went
through thank you yeah I think most of
the non our users don't know that you
can install the packages from to
multiple sources right for most of the
biology related ones it's the the first
line the source by a conductor is the
place from where you install most of the
packages right right
Koran is for all the other packages or
think this is what trafficking comes
so we're really done now it's
downloading for me so you can kinda me I
think okay so so basically what I do is
this once I you can want it low once you
have that installed you can load the day
library and that library has lots of
things actually I recently read about
some of these things from you know that
library and it has some things that
value can well you can have lots of
these the library will has multiple
things official gene names and so many
things that you can you can you can you
can you know you can convert and you can
I can work with it
so so once you have this right so what
I'm trying to do here is that I'm trying
to come change the ensemble to the gene
names here and then I'm omitting all the
rows with with with N is in there did
you get that but we were having trouble
at any point that you are having trouble
[Music]
should I go ahead yeah yeah so I'm a
nomad you are exactly I could generate
this cold actually
okay so you're able to see this plot yes
okay and how about Rajesh it's still
downloading from me all the files Tech I
think I can copy the code and I can
proceed go ahead and who's sorry I don't
get it says bit Raj what is whose Oh
who's that hi hello yeah okay okay
anyway I just want to making sure that I
kind of get people okay okay sure
oh that's all right so once you have
this right you can plot this anywhere
any gene that you take you can visualize
it using this using ggplot in general
right GG plot it takes this argument
data you first have to provide the data
okay so it's a layered approach like I
was telling this has a static mappings
coordinates it will have G ohms so
several other there are seven several
layered approach to visualization so you
the general idea would be the GG plot
and you have the data in here and any
germ function it could be a point job or
if you want to create a line it could be
a smoothing and then if the general
format is aesthetics and then you supply
a statics what these points should take
what aren't exactly colors that you want
and everything could be specified into
this mapping okay so once you have it I
would want you to run GG plot and just
data equal to DF and I want you to see
what it gives
so how many rows are there in the data
frame how do you see that how many rows
are there in data frame of you you can
view yeah but you sometimes Oh head
summary somebody gives you yeah in
general you can use summary or you can
use in rows or an intro of how many you
know the data frame you have or in
column we have so if you go to the
environment you can look into that also
all right so one see the good advantage
of using all these things I can execute
that right so here I'm executing all
these things and immediately you can see
that the data being generated it yeah
okay now I'm converting it I can run
this code and I can see at any point
right you can just look at the data here
so for instance if I'm going to merge
data I can I can run this code chunk and
it's going to immediately show me the
data in here okay inside this so I will
be able to see right now once we do this
right we will convert it and we will use
this thing the data frame and you can in
fact embed the plot in here right now
once you have embedded the plot right
what we can do is that map a color in
here right so the point of this is that
X right aesthetics is you can embed so
many colors so we have the four colors
may sell clouding lo luminal a normal
like right so what I'm trying to do is
that here I'm trying to say the color
the group by the group variable here and
it's going to immediately block me the
color right with each of these data
points will have the color associated
with this because I've made the data
frame like that actually with right so
that's the yeah yeah if you if you're
just doing
in select okay I think it's tiny murse
please not the problem
[Music]
so okay everybody up to this point yes
okay
so you'll be able to so any questions so
far on ggplot oh I have to look at the
hands on just one second okay
all right so I'm going to go ahead with
that so so so how many rows are then
that okay what are the expression values
did you plot the expression values for
idh1 and make ask
Lord of idh1 was beaten
done it
we should like in general
ours is seen a study do it like the
camera and stuffs like that right it's
yeah by the interface was exactly the
same right because in Google's
so what are the source what did you do
it's very date sometime yeah yeah
yesterday yeah yeah i'm i just finished
converting down packet i can just
quickly run through what should i do oh
okay so you are able to so what are you
able to do the scatter plot and
everything now i didn't i just download
the packets just cut down with it
completely so i just thought it the
library can just quickly go oh yeah for
a while behind oh okay okay sure so you
have which one that you were able to
download the package right yes now and
you're in the library yes
you loaded the library and you you were
able to you were able to run the the
code that okay so when i try to run that
one it said for example the gene names
uh-huh gene names not found object gene
dot names not found object gene dot
names not found yeah what does it so the
second line of code as n symbol names oh
did you run the one that was before like
this one because the gene means you have
to make what it now thanks
[Music]
we know if you have explored in here no
let's go yeah yeah I think we need to
have exploded that's a that's a you know
what export right what explore yeah
perhaps the triage in style latest
version or are just installed packages
really because this I think depends on X
score yep so he you can install our free
for free
and yeah it's c1e
that's well is the best we can please
take the paper strip oh sure so okay so
just try to install tidy words again
installed our packages yes I did should
I run it now which one I installed the
tidy wires again okay and try
recompiling it working
Thanks sometimes it
not actually very important you can
forget that but instead of using the
official gene names you can use tan
Samba ladies should this work fine so
this is just package for renaming right
side ladies to Jensen
okay so here so I'm getting an error
that says the Andean sample would not
find function select the select I think
it's the same even after reinstalling
tiny worse
yeah perhaps right so so so let's do
this okay what we are trying to okay let
me illustrate without the without there
I think this will also be a good
exercise to show okay what I'm going to
do is this I'm going to go to files to
copy the visualize visualize okay okay
so what I'm going to do is this I'm
going to not change the conversion okay
so let me take off all these conversion
things from here so what I'm going to do
is that I am just going to use the
existing ensembl IDs to do the analysis
okay so let's let's not get the ensemble
IDs here and we will just use the the
data frame okay so what I'm trying to do
here is I'm trying to take these things
when I want to make a data frame and
this data frame will have the imported
gene names right it has us six nine one
seven observations right imported RNA
seek data six nine one seven
observations and 53 variables and the
last of the 53 ways 53rd variable is the
ensembl ids right yeah how I want to
make the transpose of these okay so I'm
going to make a data frame and the data
frame is is two columns more than this
so what I need is six nine one nine
drawers right one nine rows one nine
columns right and 53 page 52 patients
okay so for the first column or the
patient IDs okay so what what are the
patient IDs let's see the first columns
we don't have the merge data
okay so the data frame one as splits
the monster data so I want to get the
column names all right that's fine
so my data frame one is going to have oh
this is the first I'm trying to create a
data frame with the first column should
have the patient names right the patient
IDs the second column should have a
group information and the rest of the
the columns of the gene name so I'm just
trying to transpose it but if you are
trying to this transpose it right let's
do a transpose of this whole RNA C can
look at how this has right
TDF should work yeah but no no that's
it's not going to give you the exact
straight water green RPC let's try to
see what this looks like this data frame
so this has group now if you look into
this right okay so look into this what
happened so you have it's fine you have
the group right and you have the the you
have the columns as gene names that's
all fine but if you look into the first
the naming of it right this is this is
just a patient ID but I want the patient
ID to be the first column right now you
can address the the row names or the
patient ID but I want the patient IDs
columns right so yes so that's one thing
that we can do but how do you add an
index column before doing a transpose so
that is what exactly that's being done
done here so I'm taking out these right
I'm adding one of these variables but
instead you can actually do that as well
so let's say that here you can take the
the column names of of you know this is
the this is a row names of here right so
let's check out the row names of a okay
you get this now we can add the data
frame you may can make a data frame
right so is a patient ID
or named Sophie
you
so this should give us the wrong inch
but at the end of the day if you are
just wanting to plot the jeans let's go
ahead and do that with her with Ensemble
ad
whatever I'm just trying to make it into
a oh they are crushed yeah yeah yeah I'm
adding this variable right I mean that's
that yeah it's yeah I'm transposing this
data yeah well yeah I mean this is I
this will automate I think this will
make it exist in the matrix last matrix
here so this will automatically may have
as natively sequel doesn't matter I have
to construct it
I have to use the heart method here I
understand such things
you still have this bandage - oh that
coursing is one of the it's a very
important concept in our so when you
have let's say that you have a list that
you have one of them is a list as a
linked list can have several data types
it could be a character or it could be
numeric constants like that so and a
half tries to read it it's going to
coerce all into one data type which is
if you are having a character and if you
are having a pneumonic the numeric
something to be converted into a
character so there are there are ways in
which you've caused certain strings you
know so Korsak not just occurs one
beware in one you have one data type to
another but there is something if you
have set of if you have set of like if
for instance if you have a string and if
you have a like for instance if you have
a double and you have a numeric
everything is going to be reversed into
a numeric so yeah so it's yeah so that's
the kind of um there are precedents in
which you can handle and this will be
covered entirely in our course that I
teach because this is I am just covering
only the visualization aspect of things
so oh we can do an ass you can you can
good numeric or mass waster yeah right
so let's go ahead and try to do the rest
of the stuff in on let's not wait for
graph okay
so instead of using the the gene names
here you can use ensembl IDs okay use
any tour normal IDs and you're going to
plot can you do some aesthetic mapping
using some Ensemble IDs instead of G
nibs that's here been able to do it i
yes and stylish I could do it yeah okay
so you are able to what what did you
know what you are able to do
[Music]
unable to get it working yes I could
plot the data frame okay so use two
ensemble instead of gene IDs right no I
know I think I use the gene IDs okay
that's great
let's go into the aesthetics okay so
these are called aesthetics and what we
can do is that we can have the variable
color instead of color we can draw you
know you can have size as an aesthetic
so these are all layers so you have a
layered approach in with you map and
then you plot whatever aesthetics that
you want and that could come under the
air the AES okay so so or we could color
to what is known as an alpha is that
axalta is the transparency you can set
the transparency for the age group okay
so I added two more variables if you if
you load this data set instead of if you
load this data set that that has yeah
here if you if you add this data set
that has other attributes such as the
age group and whether the person is
given a chemotherapy or not okay so we
can add these alpha aesthetics and and
see these are all visualization
techniques that you can add more a
static system add the same age group so
you can add the size as well as the
Alpha also what you can do with this you
can also make a shape attribute so these
are the things that brings out contrast
in your data set okay for instance we
can have we can make everything
highlight as a red okay so if you make a
GG plot with color red you're going to
have
like this so what we try to run this
code okay that I'm highlighting and see
what's wrong in here you have to tell me
why my news what does it give you
well it'll give you a scatterplot okay
and everything will be all the dots will
be in blue blue in color right is it not
blue gold is it blue or is it not blue
it's red it's red white I think I forgot
the Asian yeah why because the color is
red but the word is blue where do you
get red because the S depicts under the
ethics even the color blue is past so
actually yes that's the that's the
critical thing right I mean the color
red you map the points to red but here
you are passing the color blue inside
the aesthetics okay so that's that's a
different thing
so it's not able to interpret that yeah
yeah so these are the some of the things
that you have to be really careful when
plotting with some of these things now
let's go to face it's okay one of the
key important aspect of doing ggplot is
that we can do a face sets okay so
instead of plotting in just one you can
map it into face a graph which will give
you a distributed way of looking at
things so if you are having these four
variables like basil cloud in low
luminal a normal like you can plot it
into a matrix and that's accomplished by
what is known as a face at crack and
that's a part of layered graphics
okay so you can have the GG plot you can
plot the data frame you can map it and
then you can do a face a trap and you
will see that immediately that it gives
you in this how you can make a face a
grid if you are having more than one
categorical
what you can do is that you can plot a
GGG plot and also have an aesthetics for
these two gene system you can have the
ensemble IDs and you can plot a face at
grid okay so that's going to give you a
kind of a three dimensional information
you have the expression values in here
and you have the basal that the luminal
types the the form groups and also the
age group so with this we can be
immediately able to see some of the
information that you are not able to
observe in there for instance in if you
look at the 51 to 68 group there's no
normal like people in those age groups
or even 51 to 30 right 15 to 30 there is
no cloud in low age group people so
these are what is known as the director
insights right so here what I'm going is
that I'm making a GG plot the age group
versus the Kimo information okay and I
can immediately see that there are
people who are being given chemo
I mean there are no people in 51 to 68
school who are being given chemo I mean
who have any of these values at fgfr or
p53 right or we can see that most of
these right people have higher
expression for p53 right so these are
some of what is known as a directed
insights right these are clinical
director insights that you can observe
when you're even when you're visualizing
stuffs right in face and group rather
than you know doing a single or approach
you can you can embed multiple things in
here okay
so this is very important to see and and
you can for instance one of the exercise
is to derive directed insights for for
the variables of your choice you can try
to derive what the directed insights for
a new soil variables that you like so
that would be an exercise I would rather
go ahead and do you want me to stop and
make you a little bit work on this or
you want
get going what is your preference you
can keep going actually I think okay
okay so the next is the layered
approaches the geometric objects right
so you have these two plots on one hand
you have this and the other hand you
have this or they similar they are
actually the same if you look at it it's
just that here you have the smooth under
version and you are here have a discrete
points okay so these are known as geum's
giome is a geometrical object that you
can plot the data it could be a point
object it could be a line object or it
could be for instance a spherical object
there are so many jobs that are
available okay so if you want to see how
many jobs are available there is a there
is a there is a there is a tool to find
the jobs actually
and say yeah here so that is all 30
jumps which you can see here right so if
you if you type in okay so it will give
you all types of extensions and it will
give you lots of these themes that are
available and you can go into the
gallery and see the type of jobs and
visualization that are possible in the
plot I mean this is just amazing like
for instance here this is g0 just this
these things can be really handy when
loading some of these things so let's go
ahead with the topic so these are called
okay now for instance you can lot both
the line job and then the point job is
the same lay in the same graphics right
this is one of the biggest strengths for
for using a layered approach what you
can do is that you can embed more and
more data into the same plot that you
have and that's a biggest strength that
you have when using a layered approach
this is a totally different paradigm for
doing graphics you get that you get the
idea here yeah rather than just plotting
either of one type of a graphics you can
add more information or subtract
information or do some kind of a visual
or you can are faced X there are seven
layers actually of of using this of this
ggplot that's the grammar of graphics
and this is a seminal paper actually if
you are if you go into this I have a
I have the paper in here for those of
you who may want to read about it go to
my web page and this is the original
paper in the grammar of graphics I will
share the link with you the idea behind
the layered grammar of graphics so it's
a very important paper here so you can
go ahead and read about it it's it's a
readable people and it would say that
how it's different from the existing and
the the paradigm that you had originally
for you know plotting and how we can
have a layered approach and all the
graphics share things in common which
can be done through these things of
layered approach okay so going over
these this layered approach right as I
said you can put become overlay right
now the problem with overlaying is that
here I have had the geo move and jump
point okay and now this introduces some
kind of a duplication in our code so
let's say that you are plotting one more
thing with these variables right some
other jobs that you want to do now
it will everywhere if you want to change
one variable let's say that instead of
fgfr4 you are interested in head to
breast cancer you let's say that you're
interested in year maybe two now you
have to change everything again and
again right but instead of that what we
can do is that we can just map into one
nothing variable and then you can just
add these geum's
so it will reduce a kind of repetition
that you will have in your code okay so
it's a very important thing to actually
just have it put it in everything in one
place and then you can have a smooth or
point or any of the jobs that are
available so you don't have to really
code it again and again it's going to
produce the same kind of block
okay now there is also another thing
that we can use we can have different
aesthetics instead of having it in
different colors you can make all the
things is black right so these are the
things that you can play around with
different layers so this this this the
this idea of plotting different data to
different layers right I mean this is
this is a very powerful thing that can
bring out the contrast and that can
bring out so many hidden information in
your data okay so as a homework you
should one can try this what does a
group are human today's that it's in
line John Doe what does that group are
you meant to write you have to try it in
an example so in my class right I will
assign this and people have to do it and
then they have to submit the report in
which I would be able to grade it right
so all the things so I won't suggest you
to do all these things it's all
available let me share this my website
with you so you can try doing this
exercise see here oh sure how do I send
it to you you what is your email oh you
already have a teammate right okay so
nice one what's your deepening
all right so let's go into the next
topic that we are having here so you're
able to well you want to try out let me
go into the next topic yeah yeah that's
what I was thinking so maybe you may
want to try make one of some of these
things that we thought of we talked
about you want to try some things you
know okay so as an exercise why don't
you take two genes which is all our
genes that we are interested in right
the first set of Dyke dcn NetCam EP c
a.m. and d CM and why don't you lock
both lines a jump point and jump smooth
oh but then you have to search for this
EP cam and bcn right let me try to find
out the the mapping for these jeans in
Samba yeah I think only radish had the
issue of Ensemble right but he was able
to map the jeans anyway so it's the one
that has one one four six 500
[Music]
they're able to me since David
oh let me see the know what's that did
you did you type it in here I can find
that out mr. scribe on skype okay one
man they need you can
okay ENS G
able to map it right
a quick question yes so apart from this
waddles will be covering today we will
be seeing transformation data
transformation and exploratory data
analysis if time permits and there is
also data wrangling topics are there so
let's see if we can finish data
transformation at least so so we won't
be I mean so in yesterday's class when
we were talking about the LDA and stuff
he was saying that you you'll be
covering some part of it you won't be
doing any of that today right okay and
so you know to answer your question is
you already have the our code the
purpose of this workshop today was to
show you also how to load tables how you
see what's in the tables and the data
wrangling part will be about filtering
and making sure that the tables are
ready for the type of stuff that we did
yesterday so if you know what we're
doing today you can then easily take the
code that you downloaded yesterday and
run it on the table of things okay okay
okay okay so you have a folder our code
in yesterday's air cave and you can just
okay okay so this is like a more data
science thingy machine learning is a
part of data science but this will this
is a next step for you know for
biologists to get really hands-on doing
some data analysis okay
yeah so where are we now but when you
able to generate the graphs for simply
share the screen they want to ensure
yeah yeah
you want to shut the screen and show me
if you are having any errors or
something so this person I think
Rajesh does not have a mic parent has I
have my you have a bike can you share
your desktop to see if
also both Rajesh and Raju does not have
a mic what's up oh no no no it's okay
you can do it Ensemble I was telling you
you can do with ensemble instead of
using the team names okay but you are
doing in our marked out right okay you
don't like oh my god so forget what you
you I mean you can just take the data
frame right here right right okay so
let's take the gene names in here yeah
you mean the first card laughter all
right so let's so what does this give
you you just yeah so it's just
transposing this way that's right yeah
so aim is the transposed right right
right okay so these are the Asian Games
don't indulge in names
well but I was telling you can still
take any of these as from your data
thing and to the visualization you are
allowed
now you it's still limited to the data
frame right I mean you can just take
these transposed of these available just
chance yes right Bryce yeah this is a
little thing but we need it don't we
just need the two columns to clock right
and then oh you have to mean you don't
have to so for instance these two
ensemble IDs right so all these things
forget everything from so you can take
any of these or you can take the
transpose of these let's see
yeah I mean do we need to transform
usage yeah because you just want to take
the columns like I mean come on
something right you can work with this
yeah that's imported of it but you can
take this is it
those are transpose right good X right
you can just take the 2d magic right you
can just take the gene names and then
you can plot it you can keep everything
the same just change the DCN even DF
could be the same as possibly you can
use down something I DS here listen to
me instead of the DS PCM you can restore
normal ID instead of these two is
officially named in you can use the the
ID that he was a mystery ENS fini so if
you open this dataset
oh you know dataset I think
yeah I think it's so let's see what else
is oh wow okay so big DCM and EP cam oh
wow okay so yeah nice I just change the
demons from recoverable yeah but but you
see although it is like trying to give
you an idea of the expression values I
mean these kinds of interpolation right
you see here these are actually it's a
true far-fetched interpolation if you
have lots of points then we may be able
to say this interpolation is okay but in
general this gives an idea that the
expression values of what's at the low
middle or probably well it is similar to
the base all right I wouldn't really
call it as higher just because the
smoothing gives you a kind of a
difference sometimes it could be
misleading but but but but all you can
say is that the base L is really the
normal like between you know cloud in
low and and these two groups right yeah
okay that's neat
that's lead what do we have with Raju
and Rajesh can they share their desktop
I just say I'm glad you like this shape
they ask oh this is Rajesh sorry I think
it was I thought it was Allen okay nice
okay okay what about say he'll say here
what do you have sorry what do you have
do you want to share your screen no I
don't have anything to show as a
movement because it's me and Malik who
is doing it so I mean it's a at point
follow down to things so I'm explaining
him bit by bit
yeah okay okay so okay so we'll be
moving on to the next topic okay so this
topic is actually more data intensive so
in general right I hope you've got an
idea of how ggplot can be used you can
add more layers more jobs more physics
and physics could be really useful right
I mean if you have other information
whatever extra information you can plot
it in there and then you can look into
it and also if you see that I have have
transformed into log scale so sometimes
transforming things you know data in a
different scale might give you
unexpected different results that you
might want to you might not know like
for instance I can show you some an
example here okay
this is this is one of the diabetes data
sets you see here and I was plotting you
know two variables one is the blood
glucose level hemoglobin level called
a1c and this is the urine album in
creative ratio okay so this is the raw
data which was like this
now when you plot these variables but
when you just take the log
transformation right I'm just plotting
the log and you see that there are two
clusters so I mean this is just a simple
logarithm can give you some insights
that you will not be able to probably
see if you don't you know if you don't
take such transformations so it's very
important to you know see how your data
behaves like I was telling you the first
place right I mean it's about curiosity
and like you know data science is mostly
driven by curiosity and the mix comes
the rest of the stuff that's a main
engine and you have to play with your
data set becomes
arise I mean be friends with your data
set and see what this trying to say the
first place I mean 80% of data science
is actually data cleaning and doing all
these things the rest of the 20% is
probably machine learning and doing some
of the inference and stuff like that so
I would suggest you to play with the
data
okay now playing with the data right I
mean that comes to an extremely
important topic which is transformation
and exploration all right so this is the
this is not our data set I didn't have
you know we should it's not an RNA seek
data sets it's a diabetes data set but
the rest of the principle remains the
same instead of this data set you can
just plug in our data set which is there
in that website and it should all work
the same okay so we will first import
the curated Haines data set it's just
going to be the same idea here what we
are trying to do is that you are taking
the latest online I put it there as a
CSV file and this are see URL is going
to take in for this data set and I'm
reading in the gender the age group and
there are a couple of other variables in
here and I'm just going to see how the
data set looks like okay so STR this
variable right STR that shows how the
structure of this data set is so we have
a regular data frame in here you have
the key which is the patient ID the
gender of the patient the age the age
group the patient belongs to and how how
health condition is at excellent very
good acceptor etcetera some of these
variables like unit variables you
created in new album in our own urine
variables and there are some blood
variables in here cadmium there are some
glucose variables etcetera etcetera
so that's that's the general idea of the
data set okay so there are instead of in
general the data set that you receive
right it could be really huge so to
compress it there
something called a stable okay so the
tables are just nothing but data frames
but they have I mean no that are that
they knows extremely limited amount of
things that data frames can do but they
are good for viewing and doing some ad
hoc stuffs so instead of dealing with a
the entire data frame tables can be much
cleaner and more expressive code okay so
tables you can convert usually in are
anything that you can convert can be
done as ask dot click for instance if
you want to convert a list into vector
and you can say it's a start vector or
if you want to convert into you know
logical you can say a stock logical so
similarly it tables can be converted
into a store table and change data set
is can be converted into tables okay so
we'll just make it a table and then just
looking into it as a table right instead
of looking at a structure this is going
to just give me how the table looks like
so so then when we do the transformation
there are six types of transformations
okay so these are extremely important
types of transformation you can operate
on drawers or you can operate on columns
or you can create new variables and the
most important of all the transformation
is a group by we will talk about it in
detail okay so this is a very important
transformation and these are the six
transformations that are extremely
important and will be usefully any type
that you work with the data so the
filter function right the filter
function will allow you to pick a subset
of information so when you have a data
frame let's say that in your RNA seek
data we just want to find all people
whose age group lies between 41 and 50
and who's you know DCM gene is fine you
can just filter in this data set what
I'm trying to do is I'm taking the
entire data set I want the age to be 45
and the HDL the high cholesterol the
good cholesterol right the high the good
cholesterol I wanted to be fifty so it's
going to give me those values in here
okay actually I try to do this with our
own data set in fact 4x I started
working with our dataset let me show you
the transformation transform our MD so I
am importing the data set here for RNA
seek right and the same I'm making it an
official gene name and this is so one of
the biggest problem in using table is
that the the column name should be
different okay it should be unique gene
names if you are having the same names
it's going to complain and so we have to
do some kind of a we have to only
extract the unique gene names and that's
what I'm doing here I am trying to take
and I'm I'm removing the duplicate of
gene names and only using the unique
gene names in here okay now the table
doesn't give any errors and it's called
I have to tell us
okay okay so now it's not going to give
me any errors and it's going to give me
the table okay and we also add the age
group and PMO information just like that
okay so okay filter right so I'm just
selecting for the group as luminol and
the fgfr4 gene values less than five
right it's a simple function so this is
going to give me all the values for all
the all the patients whose group is
luminal and it's going to give you the
fj-4 for value less than five okay and
similarly you can look for free age
group so the filter function actually
filters cerullo's okay and all of these
these are called deep layer okay deep as
a deep layer DPL why are functions okay
they are going to create a new data
frame okay so it's important that we
assign these to a new variable and then
use it usually that's that's and also we
can use comparison logical operators so
for instance here using this ATM gene
and I want the groups between thirty
hundred forty and you know the ATM value
so you can use logical operators inside
the filter function similarly you can
this is just for a Kimo the same example
where the Kimo function is fine right so
what are the key things to notice that
the filter only includes rows where the
condition is true and it also excludes
both falls and any values okay so as an
example find this find all patients who
are not given chemotherapy and have p53
levels greater than five so can you do
this exercise these are this
should not take too long
can repeat the conditions Oh
what sorry the questions yeah oh sorry
one second
okay so useful okay you know if you use
this you don't really need any of the
team names if you you can just cut and
paste it it should work fine oh yeah
what's the dataframe here lowly this
doesn't have to do anything with jeans
oh the data set that I have
yes lots of remedies data set
oh what's that Sonny what's the
dataframe baby we don't have a data
frame right
oh okay the data frame is just the same
data frame that we had last time in that
visualization so you I thought this is
Rajesh right yes and you got the G
official gene names the data frame is
just the same data frame
ensuring the screen yeah yeah it's
following these questions
like can you see a screen oh hi
can I see your screen Rajesh
she don't mind yeah actually I can cut
and paste it in
all the unique light okay let me give
you that sorry I think it's giving you
the other that you don't have the unique
how do we get the column names like what
what column names you what is the name
of the column all the other dog to
filter through like a group that's
that's the the column name like oh you
mean at the age group and all these
column names of the gene names right and
not the congos a filtering through rows
right sorry I mean yeah it will keep so
it will keep only the rows so it will
take each column right and those rows
out which does not meet the criteria
yeah hmmm but how do we know the names
of what the rows for example he said if
this example the second condition here
said in the age group 41 to 50 right
right
movemove type so the age group what's
the column name a row name or the filter
name is it like age group no no the see
here right
for instance I'm taking p53 should be
greater than so how do you know that
this P P P 53 oh that's the gene of
interest that you are interested in
right I mean there are 7,000 genes right
I mean for example here it said the
second one it says group between forty
one fifty and have a luminal type
alright so for if you go back to the
history right luminal type is if we say
the group is equal to the luminal then
we select the rows with the luminal type
right right where do you get that name
group all that is the initial data
right I mean that's why you've found
this data frame so it's best to form a
data frame especially with the group
information I added this group
information right so so here I say that
column names unique this patient ID and
group yeah so how do we find the for
example it said every data frame but I
want to know what are all the names that
are column names you call names right so
this is co l okay of DF thanks reviewed
all the column names in here okay you
paste it in your everything yes not
everything just take the fortune
so oh yeah you got it so yeah here I
know right and
this is you can you make us a table here
oh we are in you are in Center
[Music]
we were able to find the pigs right
David it's obvious good right okay so
what are we waiting on somebody to show
something or oh yeah we are rough let's
see oh so okay so you need to type in
luminol yeah that's right oh let's see
Oh equal equal yeah
I still get the same a little bit
I mean still in me
to hear me Polly let me look into your
court okay fine
so DF just type DF yeah
or test type there yeah okay so the DF
is already there right I think what it's
trying to do is when you type in filter
yeah you already loaded the library
right the the tidy verse yeah
so just filter DF and what is your what
what data frame is it just that data
frame or did you have anything else in
here I can now make
that they'd be afraid at 52 observations
and 6680 two variables right yeah that's
you see here it's only in men moment
they see that yeah
and 52 observations of 660 okay so this
put tp53 greater than five I think man
we are crash oh okay
you
should I be loading everything again
okay that's okay
can I go back to history or something
[Music]
history no I think oh you need not save
the are markdown or anything no yeah you
should be able to find if you are if you
have it in your history just try looking
into the history or you know just cut
and paste you don't have to work with
the gene data set but you can work with
the with the diabetes dataset okay it is
there in my lips I can give you exactly
the making the page so that should be
easy
this cutter basically should be fine
exactly oh oh the pipe symbol
here you can go into this and okay you
should be seen
yeah I did save so probably you just
need to yeah it should be fine yeah and
the data frame is hints yes and I have
the port in there
[Music]
what is it few vendors
so object hate still not found see it's
the audience right is there let's see
age group all the age group is an
integer right so yeah but even me I
tried without I know it's not a string
so I just I the integer the first filter
within work like 20 did you try the
first one filter SP is equal to 45 and
HDL equal to 50 yeah this one right yeah
just running it oh it's still not found
oh why is that
type in hints yeah
scroll down a little bit listen yeah
alright here's true equal sign okay
it's a relationship in one single cosine
to equal sign is that equal to if it
matches that right it's number is not or
did you type in tiny volts load the
library oh well it's bit spotter for
that library right so why is that I and
you know that I divorce library it's
already part of I thought I'd load at
the time oh yeah maybe it should load
the tiny verse sale load not tiny verse
label it up try diverse yeah just trying
that okay yeah it should won't take yeah
yeah now try it
yeah you can filter by okay yeah so yeah
I think that works
yeah all right so let's look an external
ones okay so I think this is fine I'm
not going to spend too much time in here
okay so no one's come and eat how many
patients are missing you ACR values in
the Haynes data set you have to use na
is dot na yes dot na so yeah all right
let's go into the next so that's the
filter function and another important
function is what is known as a range
function okay
just like how filter filters out the
role arrange works like similar similar
to filter but it changes the order okay
so it will not filter but it will change
the order so for instance if you say
arrange change by gender and age order
by the descending order of these you
created in okay so that's going to order
these in the value of descending order
of the you creative in value okay so
it's going to take the SV age and then
age group and then it's going to by the
descending order
you can also also use tail and head
functions okay so you can use tail and
that's going to give you the bottom
values and it's also you going to give
you the head a hint also gives the top
portions of it okay so sort the Haynes
to find patients with highest or a
strong can you do that
data frame dart arranged yeah no data
frames Tata raised its data frame it's
arranged just like filter it's arranged
the data frame and then the work
variable that you want to arrange it
could be gender or age or okay it
doesn't matter what's the question we
arrange Brahma the highest cholesterol
so it's in the descending order of
cholesterol right yeah yeah do you see
deac are using you don't have eat it's
not equal to but you just say deac
descending order of cholesterol
total see ya all right okay
let's go to the next one select like
instead of just like using a filter and
arrange for rows use select four columns
okay so the select is going to choose
the columns so here is the code where
you select only the the haemoglobin and
glucose right so you take s a select the
Haynes data set and a1c and glucose so
it's as simple as that and it's going to
give you the a1c at glucose right I mean
it's just going to select only those
columns and there is also an help an
argument it says everything
okay so that's going to select
everything keep it was going to keep a
1c and glucose in the front but the rest
of that is going to keep everything
other than it's going to push the rest
of the stuff so here it's going to take
the a1c a glucose and it's going to put
everything else after that okay so
that's a very useful thing to do and
there is another important function
called the mutate the mutate
what it does is that it creates new
variables from the existing variable so
you can add new columns let's say that
you have a you have a data set in which
you have time and you have data set with
this
you can create a new column saying speed
equal to distance by time right so
that's that's something that you can
make and this is for instance here write
this code makes a new variable that's a
sum of the high cholesterol the good
cholesterol and the bad cholesterol and
it's going to store in this value HL
to find the ratio between the
cholesterol right and I'm going to do so
what I'm trying to do is here I am only
selecting a subset of the Haynes dataset
in which I select the Haynes LDL
estimate cholesterol total triglyceride
etc and I'm trying to make a new
variable H underscore ell and I'm adding
these two variables and then forming
another variable is called ratio okay I
mean this is for diabetes but in general
you can take do it for gene expression
if you want to form another variable
that is a sum of or you know the you see
how one gene expression is related to
the other
Rajeshwari biologists right or no yes
okay so you can do the same thing you
can form the new you know estimate which
is say mutate so that is what the
metadata is going to do so this theta
gives you that the HL and the ratio here
okay
the transmute will only keep those
variables will only retain the created
variables and it will not retain any of
the prior variables so that's called
transmute and there are lots of useful
functions like lag lead except I we can
wrap around these things and you can
take the top function that is made out
of the filter function actually these
are rappers but you know you can use
these things like you can stop
underscore n we'll take the top five
values of the ratio okay so these are
some important functions especially
mutate you will be using a lot actually
yeah yeah you can yeah you can introduce
a new column to the data frame like that
as well
right so the biggest benefit of using a
mutate is that usually when you create
the new variable you are no working not
in data frames but you're working with a
subset of data frames and tables and
things like that so if you are creating
a new variable with mutate you would
typically use with additional like for
instance calling let's say that you have
a new variable called you know which is
probably you know that's made up off you
don't have to really use the columns
right I mean when you when you put it
under the table format you can just use
the column information rather than the
data information from there so let's say
that you want to create a new variable
called speed when you are given distance
and time how do you really do that
within the data frame yeah divide how
how would you divide actually like if
you had a dollar you're forming new
speed speed and no that is a list right
what goes on to the right hand yeah try
it out how does how do you create dollar
so that will take know right right so
the operations right they have defined
under mutate actually as soon as you are
doing some calculation right yeah so
instead of using far loop and creating
another thing this is already built in
things that's done okay so
so this is them by far the most
important thing that you would use in
data sciences that the group by and
summarize functions okay so these are
very critical functions let's say that
you have a group of genes that fall
under some pathway and you want to see
that what's a mean expression of the
pathway right what you can do is that
you can use a group by operation okay so
for instance here I have chains by
gender I want to group by gender male
and female and I want to take the mean
cholesterol level so what I do is this I
take group by the Haynes data set I grew
by the gender and I want to take the
mean cholesterol okay so this is going
to give me a dataset table with gender
for male it's 183 and for female it's
187 okay so that's that's the importance
of group I so if you are having a bunch
of genes and if you want to take the
mean expression or if you are working
with a probe set data and you want to
convert into genes you can use this into
you know use the group by operation all
right okay so the summaries also has
useful functions called the count okay
summarizes several functions such as the
count such as the mean etc etcetera so
for instance that here is an analysis
where you take the HDL and LDL for each
group and go by the number of patients
with particular AIDS okay so what I do
is that by age I grew by AIDS with the
age information and I take the mean HDL
mean LDL and I count where the group of
more than five people or remove more
than five people right so and then I
plot the data so this is using the
visualization and then you see that you
see the count of how the distribution is
this is H and this is L that's the the
mean HDL and LDL
and I plot the number of people who are
more than five HDL versus the mean HDL
versus their LDL okay by the by the age
group right by the age category all
right so the biggest disadvantage is
that often when you're doing data signs
using these things you will you will be
using the variables again and again
which can be eliminated with a pipe
symbol this is called the pipe symbol
okay so as the analysis becomes
complicated by piping will become
extremely useful so like for instance
what you can do is that you can fight
this information into this and again you
can summarize it okay so this is called
a piping and piping is a very important
useful function that you will always use
in using this okay
missing values is typically used by this
function in a dot 3rm so that will you
can remove the missing values and and
for instance here right you can use with
without removing n/a there is a
difference with you sometimes usually
it's best to remove data set with any
because those are the things that can
really cause some problems effects all
you can summarize the mean could be
different right I mean if you are not
using the n/a or using the nd it could
matter when you consider the number of
people and stuff like that so it's very
important to actually remove the any
values first and then you can take the
values and you can take the mean or
aggregation okay what's it can we fill
in the values but they can say yeah you
can do that actually that's that comes
under the randall portion of it we'll
cover it later
maybe not today but there is a whole
bunch of how to deal with such things
right I mean there is a whole science
behind doing filling the missing values
you can do an interpolation
you can take an average and so many
other things and those are all possible
we can do an aggregation using group I
it's usually it also the people use
account information to soul here chains
your grouping by age and gender and
summarizing it right and we can also
plot the count information and using
what is known as a job we saw there are
so many jobs right Polly frequency of
the polynomial is also a job so we can
plot along with these jobs to see the
count distribution okay so that's going
to give you that so some of these things
right we have to play with the data set
to see how you know so you can use your
own data set to find all these point
jobs of smooth smoothing function so at
this point I would actually you know ask
you to do some basic things of you know
apply this to the RNA seek data set for
the genes of your interest and then give
the results I would say that I think
that would be the one of the exercises
that you can try it out maybe you know
you can try to find this form but you
know have to import all the stuffs right
maybe you can try to do it for HDL right
I use do this example one for HDL
and
what are we doing a grouping by way
unless you're grouping by the exercises
to actually grouping by the age group
and you're trying to find the mean HDL
and hence TL glucose container so no I'm
just giving you an exercise for this
based on exactly one you have to do with
instead of cholesterol total rate for
HDL in our mouths down if you just press
it in obligated if you're not using our
markdown oh then yeah oh no you should
just press Enter it's going to the next
line but if you want to close it right
yeah but I think you know if you don't
really complete it it will not going to
turn a plus so I have the same problem
so if I press ENTER it's it's running
the function what do you do
oh is it not so let me see here right
right so let's
yeah let's know this
okay it's a shift enter so here right so
if you do this it's going to have a plus
okay it's going to add plus but if you
want to close it like this because right
so here right so if you want to write oh
you want to yeah yeah you windows so you
got it
it's mean what HDL yeah so exercises
just to replace cholesterol with mean
HDL so you can see this you can inside
cholesterol total you can specify the
glucose variable to
in this cut and paste it I guess
oh you have to specify who its data
frame that you are working with so you
know yeah but yeah that should well yeah
you can do that but actually you you
have you the business to pipe actually
from one result to the other so
typically you know that's the importance
of piping like you know now I got the
comes of piping yeah so you can put the
result from Jane's and then it you you
put it and then it will direct all the
data to here and then it out all right
great so you know with this I would
suggest you to work through some of the
exercises and feel free to reach out to
me see here you have not given the
results right I mean you have not piped
in the results but I would suggest you
know to work on these things the more
you work right it's better that's the
key about things about data Sciences or
bioinformatics for that matter is you
know anything for that matter the more
you work you do you mess in your hands
the better it's going to be so I would
suggest you to you know work on these
things whenever it and let me feel free
to reach out to me anytime okay yeah
sure so I think we will stop here it's
all be three hours today case would be
exhausted so let's try to see if we can
meet some time here all right thank you
very much alright so yeah have a good
and we'll meet sometime yeah thank you
yeah but I think it's one of the best
things for data science all these tiny
words is a very good package
I heard of tidy or something oh but
Eddie immerse and type typing P that was
the difference try er yeah there are
some very odd
so try divorce is a big package that has
tiny was ggplot Khidr and then the flyer
everything is packaged your pic so many
other things yeah